from birthdays to holidays to weddings
the pandemic has forced many of us to
put life's celebrations on hold
but imagine if your life's work is
planning those celebrations
that's the case for jess gordon once
named by harper's bazaar as the top
wedding and event designer in the world
our jamie wax sat down with gordon to
talk about her new challenges her new
book
and what the future may hold
for the last decade jess gordon has been
known in the high-end party industry
as the rock star event planner could you
ever have imagined
that the entire field you've given your
life to to work in
would all literally just vanish one day
no it's kind of like a tsunami and
honestly it's my
toughest spot what are you doing with
all of that
creativity and drive that you have
inside of you right now
i'm just thinking a lot i'm taking a
pause and i'm trying to visualize my
future which is
really hard to do i'd like you to meet
jess gordon
hey guys at the height of her career
gordon was a regular on a reality show
with celebrity chef
rocco de spirito now it's still in
progress
you like i can't believe you did it and
traveling around the world with a
thriving event production company
i think people think that event
producers live very shiny lives because
we sell luxury
we drink the finest champagnes we travel
all over the world a lot of these things
are comped because we're bringing
business
to those things but a lot of the times
too we're living hand to mouth
i do not have a dime i have no problem
saying that
every dime that i've made i've put back
into my company
to keep growing it i don't like being 50
and not knowing what my future is i've
worked too hard for that
that lavish lifestyle is described in
detail in her fictional account of the
industry
party on the moon how close to real life
is the book you know i think some of
those aspects are very very real
a lot of the experiences mirrors some
pretty awesome times in my life
so this is me as a very young girl out
in north carolina
doing one of my very first weddings
gordon grew up in poughkeepsie new york
at age 13 she got her first job as a
florist assistant
and by 20 her love of floral arranging
had blossomed into her own event
production firm
at what point did you realize and this
is going to be a very very
long time when i left my office on march
13th
i kind of thought i wasn't coming back
and then
certain clients like l'oreal paris
called and said we're a full go and i
was like okay yay
you know we'll produce this out of my
apartment no biggie and then when they
canceled
a month later that's when i knew that
was it
she moved out of her luxury apartment in
one of manhattan's most expensive
neighborhoods
come here and back in with her mother
and poughkeepsie
what is it like being back it's surreal
it's
hard to describe actually because
there's moments that it feels so safe
and wonderful
and then there's other moments where i
just feel completely claustrophobic
just with the general circumstances i
also haven't lived with another human
being for a very long time let alone my
mother
describe for me what happened when you
realized this was
what your lives would be my place in
this
is to support her nobody could have
predicted this
and this is very difficult and it's a
period of grieving and i think you have
to recognize that
and while she's waiting for the return
of huge celebrations
the events she's planning now are the
small everyday moments
of thankfulness that's sort of what's
going to pull us all through i think to
try and find
moments of gratitude things to be
grateful for
we have to every day above ground is a
good day
period and i don't know what's going to
happen in the future
let me just get through today let me
have my dreams maybe i do want to open
up a flower shop maybe tomorrow i don't
want to
that's okay let me vacillate i'm going
to fly like a little butterfly in the
breeze
until i land somewhere that feels good
instinctively an update for you since we
shot the story gordon has moved out of
her mother's house and made plans to
open up that flower shop
in 2020 well good for her you know this
is like a time though a lot of people
may pivot may make the decision to do
something completely different
a lot of people had no choice about it